[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Well, let
me start by giving just a bit
of background on David for those
who don't know him personally
and his story, and then
we'll just dive right.
In and we'll chat a little bit
and have some conversation.
But we're going to open
it up to live questions,
and we also have
a Dory available.
I know we have a lot of Googlers
on the live stream as well,
and so the Dory is go--
Robin?
ROBIN: go IRC dash Dory.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Yeah-- go
IRC dash Dory for the Googlers
on live stream who want
to ask a question as well.
DAVID MILIBAND: Great.
Good to be here.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Let me
give a little bit of background
on you for those who
don't know already.
DAVID MILIBAND: This
will put them off.
No,
JACQUELLINE FULLER: I think
it adds many dimensions.
All right.
So we know David is
president and CEO of the IRC,
which for those who don't
know was founded in 1933
at the request of Albert
Einstein offering emergency aid
as well as long-term
assistance--
something that we were
just talking about,
that important pivot--
to those who are displaced
by war, persecution,
and natural disaster.
So the IRC is now
operating in more than 40
war-affected countries
and also doing
Refugee Resettlement, an
assistance program here
in the US in 28 cities.
DAVID MILIBAND: We've had to
close three offices because
of the current administration,
so now 25 US cities.
We'll come back to that.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: We will
come back to that point.
I think interestingly
though, for folks
who don't know David's story
before coming in and taking
the helm of the IRC--
so he's been a public servant
in the UK for many years holding
various posts from being
the 74th secretary of state
for foreign affairs, secretary
of state for the environment,
and a member of parliament
for South Shields.
Who knows if public service
is going to be in the future
as well?
So very, very glad to have
him here with me today.
We have become not only friends
and colleagues, but our teams
and all across
Google-- we have been
deeply integrated into the
work of the IRC thinking
about various ways
that Google can
be helpful because of the heroic
work that they are doing day in
and day out on the front line.
So David, it might be helpful
to just begin with the why--
why this issue is
important for you.
DAVID MILIBAND: Well, I
think it's important really
for two reasons.
First of all, thank you very
much, Jackie, for hosting this.
And thanks to all
of you for coming,
and thanks to people
online for the questions
they're going to ask.
It's important to me
for two reasons, really.
One is just the
simple personal reason
that both my parents
were refugees.
My dad was a refugee from
Belgium in 1940 to the UK.
My mom was a refugee
from Poland in 1946.
She came as a very young
girl on her own to the UK.
So there's a certain sense
in which the current refugee
crisis is kind of in my blood.
It's part of who I am.
I know that if the
UK had not admitted
refugees in the '40s and '50s,
then I wouldn't be here today.
My parents would never have met.
And so there's something
quite personal about it.
But there's also the fact that
it's more and more striking
that we live in a world where
the number of wars between
states is at an all time
low, but the number of people
fleeing violence is
at an all time high--
at least all time since records
began after the Second World
War--
25 million refugees, 40 million
people internally displaced.
Those 65 million
people are not moving
in the search of a better life.
They are fleeing
for their lives.
They are the baker born from
the home and bakery in Damascus.
They are the girl chased from
her school in Northeast Nigeria
by Boko Haram.
We have 1,000
staff inside Syria.
They are the people
who are being bombed
by conventional weapons
and now by chemical weapons
in eastern Damascus.
And these people who are
victims of war and persecution--
they pose some of the most
difficult public policy issues
about how you can help them
survive and how you can help
them thrive--
how you can, above all, get
to the roots of the challenges
they face.
But they also pose moral
questions about what
responsibilities the West--
which I see as a political
construct, not just a
geographic construct--
Western countries
that in some ways
defined a world order
after the Second World War
based on the
sovereignty of states
but also the rights
of individuals--
how that is defended.
And it seems to me that
it's tragic but true
that in the second decade
of the 21st century
the fundamental issues of
whether or not victims of war
have rights is now at issue,
at stake, at risk in a way
that it hasn't
been for 70 years.
And so it's really a
mixture of, if you like,
the heart and the head that make
the issues around displacement,
war, conflict, persecution--
something that I've been
feel very privileged to spend
the last four years working on.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: I mean,
you just touched on this.
But as we were
walking over, we were
talking about why this
issue matters so much.
And it matters because it
says so much about who we are
as humanity-- how we
treat those most--
DAVID MILIBAND: I
mean, when I started
working for the International
Rescue Committee,
I had this naive
belief that we were
about rescuing other people.
It turns out that that's
true, but we're also
in the business of rescuing
some of the deepest values
and principles and
commitments that
have made this country just
to take that as an example.
When it's done
great things, it's
often done it on the basis of
some very important values,
principles, and precepts.
And that work of rescue--
that work of keeping
people alive in Syria,
giving people dignity in
Congo or in Bangladesh,
ensuring that kids can get an
education-- half of the world's
refugees are children,
but less than 2%
of the global humanitarian
budget goes on education.
Giving educational opportunity
to those young people--
that goes to the heart of what
we say we are as a society--
what the Western world
says it stands for.
And the truth is that we do an
injustice to our own history,
but we also hand an
easy baseball bat
to those who would challenge
the West as being full of
hypocrisy rather than full
of goodwill and good intent
when we fail to live
up to those standards.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
And it might be
helpful for those
in the audience
who don't have as much
background on the issue--
I know several of you
are deeply knowledgeable
and experts on this-- but
also a plug for David's most
recent book as
well, which I think
is a great read,
a compelling read,
and also I think
a great synopsis
of where we are, how we got
here, and the path forward.
But for folks who don't
have as much context,
I think, for example,
people are surprised.
They hear refugee,
maybe refugee camp.
They don't understand how long
people will tend to be there
and how important
integration is.
DAVID MILIBAND:
That's a great point.
Thank you for what you
said about the book.
The other thing I would say--
it's short.
It's not 140 characters.
It's not 280 characters,
but it will take you an hour
and a half to two hours to read.
If you listen to
the audio version,
it's two and 1/2
hours of my voice.
It was rather chilling for
me when one of my colleagues
said to me that they
were enjoying waking up
with me every morning.
I found that rather chilling.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: We
don't say those things here.
DAVID MILIBAND: But he meant
it in the nicest possible way.
Let me give a bit of context
which involves some statistics.
I've told you there are 65
million people displaced
from their homes by
conflict and disaster.
But the idea I want you to hold
on to through the statistics
is that we've got a refugee
crisis not just because
of the number of people
involved but because
of the nature of
the crisis itself,
and that nature
goes to the issues
of the length of displacement,
the location of displacement
as well.
So just three things
really-- first of all,
it's hard to measure.
But we think-- the UN thinks--
that the average length of
displacement for a refugee
is 10 years.
So you're out of your
own country for 10 years.
But once you've been out of
your own country for five years,
the average displacement
goes up to 21 years.
So hold onto the idea that we're
in a wholly new world where
the job of public
policy of citizens
is not just to keep
refugees alive.
Remember, the Second World
War went on for six years.
The job is not just to
keep people alive so
that they can then go home.
The likelihood is is that
they're not going to go home.
Because the Civil
War in Afghanistan
has effectively been
going on since 1979.
The war in Somalia has
effectively been going on
since the early 1990s.
The wars in the Congo have
been effectively going
on for 30 or 40 years.
The outlier is the
Lebanese Civil War,
which lasted 15 years
but then ended in 1990.
And frankly, Lebanon
is as good as it gets
for restoring fragile peace.
But the more likely scenario
is that these fragile states
are marked by recurrent wars
rather than wars that end.
So the first point is the
length of displacement changes
the challenge.
Secondly, most refugees
are not in refugee camps.
I get often asked, oh, you
must work in refugee camps,
and we do.
But 60% of the world's
refugees are in urban areas,
not in camps.
So again, it changes the game.
The perils are different,
but the possibilities
are different if you're
living in an urban area rather
than a refugee camp.
There are four million
refugees more or less
in camps, almost all of
them in sub-Saharan Africa.
The third thing, I think,
is really important--
is that you'd think
from the media coverage
that most refugees are in
rich countries like this one.
But the US has 1% of
the world's refugees.
Europe has 6% of the
world's refugees.
88% of the world's refugees are
in poor or lower middle income
countries.
So Lebanon has 1 and
1/2 million refugees.
Jordan has probably
800,000 refugees.
Kenya has a million refugees.
Ethiopia has a million refugees.
Iran has 800,000 Afghans who
have been there for 30 years.
And so the phenomenon
of global responsibility
is in the mean exercised
by poor countries and lower
middle income countries,
not by rich countries.
And it's countries like
Bangladesh, which is
fragile in all sorts of ways--
it's got massive population
that's growing fast.
It's just had 900,000
Rohingya Muslims arrive
from Myanmar next door in
the space of six months.
And the minute you start doing
the maths about what would it
mean for a country like this if
that kind of numbers of people
if it was proportioned up,
you'd see the kind of challenge
that it poses even for a
country like Bangladesh which
is doing the right
thing and opened
its doors to those refugees.
Jordan, which is the
second closest ally
of the US in the Middle East--
its debt to GDP ratio
has gone from 50% to 90%.
It's the resource stress
on its water supplies
and other supports--
schools, its hospitals--
massively increased.
And there isn't
yet a response that
gives Jordan or
countries like it
the kind of support it needs.
And what I argue in the
book is that this crisis
is manageable but
only if we change
the way that we manage it.
And that means shifting
our focus from the fiction
that there's a short-term
problem of survival
and recognize this is
a long-term challenge
of helping people thrive
rather than just survive.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
And thinking about how
others can support the IRC--
I just learned
recently that the IRC
is one of the most beloved
nonprofits by our employees,
by Googlers.
We have more than
5,000 Googlers who
are personal donors to the IRC.
So I think there's increasing
the commitment and engagement
of just everyday folks,
Googlers or not, and donations.
As a company, we've also
been thinking about--
so we've donated, I think,
about $6 million to the IRC
as Google.org.
And we've also been
thinking about how can we
take the best of who we are?
How can we take
our tech expertise?
You all saw the
video about info hub.
That's an example of how
we're thinking about that.
But David, you're speaking
here to this audience.
What do we need to know?
What do we need to hear
about how we can best
support the work
that you're doing
either as Google or as other
folks across the Bay Area?
DAVID MILIBAND: The nice
thing about being here
is that I can in person say
thank you to those of you who
have stepped up to support us.
And the most important
thing I can say both
to those who are
supporting us or those
who are thinking
about it is something
that I hope you
believe, which is
that you come to believe
through discussions like this
that actually you can
make a difference.
Although this is
a global problem,
it is susceptible to
local individual response.
And just to pick out a
couple of aspects to it--
one thing is genuinely
unique about the IRC.
We are both an international
humanitarian aid organization
and a local resettlement agency.
So a refugee who's given
permission to come to the US--
we meet them at the airport.
We get their kids into school.
We help them on the
track to employment.
You've been there?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID MILIBAND:
You're a refugee?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I am.
DAVID MILIBAND: Where
are you a refugee from?
AUDIENCE: I worked
for IRC in Bosnia
during the Bosnia conflict.
DAVID MILIBAND: Can we hear
him, or does he need a mic?
AUDIENCE: Do you need me
to stand up over here?
DAVID MILIBAND: Well,
you are standing up.
AUDIENCE: Good
afternoon, everybody.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID MILIBAND: Do
you work at Google?
AUDIENCE: No.
Actually, I arrived in San
Francisco as a refugee.
I arrived at the SFO.
As David said, there were
three IRC representatives
waiting for me 27 years ago.
I came here.
We settled, lived in [INAUDIBLE]
for about eight years.
[INAUDIBLE] was the first spot.
Got a job in a week with the
help of IRC and Silicon Valley,
worked for PRI and
Intel for years.
After learning the scopes of--
as you said, there's no
way to go back to Bosnia,
because it was a mess
until almost the '90s.
Make a permanent residency here,
between a US citizen in 2000,
got married here.
My kid is born here.
We still go back to
Bosnia every other year.
We visit.
My mom's there.
My family's there.
By me being here, I
provide support for them.
And that was the original idea.
When I left IRC--
Sarajevo and IRC
[INAUDIBLE] office in 1994.
So the idea was
to come somewhere
where it's better to get
an opportunity to thrive.
I was 22 years old when I came.
So long story short, I'm still
here with a Oakland commute
to cross the Bay Bridge
every day as most of you do.
I'm trying to help and a big
advocate of IRC for years.
I can generally
say if you really
want to get involved locally,
Oakland office is great.
They really do
need help to teach
good English, to teach people
how to go to a grocery store.
You can pick the car and
drive them around for one day.
You can learn a
different culture.
Believe me, you're going
to have some good food.
I help as much as I can.
I know Karen.
I know Maggie.
I know Samir.
Samir and I used to
work together years ago.
Mark Bartolini is a very
good friend of mine.
So I do help locally as
much as their kindness.
DAVID MILIBAND: I promise
you that is not staged.
But really, thank you for that.
What you have said far more
eloquently than I could
is that one of the great
things about the IRC
is it works across
the arc of crisis.
It's got a bird's-eye view from
the war zone to the neighboring
state to the refugee transit
route to the lucky few getting
resettled here.
But I can say to you in Oakland,
in Sacramento, in San Jose,
in Turlock, you can volunteer
to make a difference
to someone's life.
And if you want to make
the world better, doing it
one life at a time is
a good place to start.
So the first thing is to say
the refugee crisis doesn't
have to be far away.
It can be close by.
The second thing that
I think is important--
today, five Googlers
are in Jordan
helping turn that refugee
info into a platform
that refugees in Jordan across
the Middle East can use.
And they're there
for three weeks.
They're working with our teams.
So we bring the humanitarian
expertise or our teams
do, you bring the
technological expertise.
We don't say
there's a technology
solution to every problem.
But it is very, very striking
like you heard on the video
that the first
thing a refugee will
do if they land in
Greece or anywhere else
is they'll take their
mobile phone out.
And they'll often
ask, where am I?
And so the work that's going
on that is really valuable.
I had the number.
It said on the screen
that it was 180,000.
I thought it was 800,000 who
had used the refugee info.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID MILIBAND: Since the video,
hundreds of thousands of people
have used and
benefited from that.
And this is going to sound
like a really hokey point
to technology--
so my first question when
I went onto this site
was, it's a bit dark.
Why is it so dark?
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
It's not very pretty
DAVID MILIBAND: It's not pretty.
It's dark.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
But boy, it loads fast.
DAVID MILIBAND: The answer
was an interesting one,
because it speaks to
the thoughtfulness that
went into it.
Well, we don't want
it to be pretty,
and we don't want
it to be bright.
Because we want it to
use up much less battery.
Sorry to say.
It's kind of an obvious
point, but to me it
wasn't an obvious point.
There's real
thoughtfulness that's
gone into making sure this
is the most valuable resource
for the people.
So that's the second thing.
Thirdly, last fiscal year we
raised $1.8 million dollars
thanks to Google employees
committing and Google.org
matching.
I think it was a one to one
match or possible a two to one
match.
So that makes a
difference as well,
because we know that we can
vaccinate a child for $50.
We know that we can run a
women's center for $2,500.
We know that we can
make a big difference
for small sums of money as long
as many people are part of it.
And so the fact the Google
community has invested
like that I think is important.
The final thing that
I would just say
is a plea for you
to use your voice.
Use your voice with your family.
Use your voice with
your neighbors.
Use your voice with your
congressman or woman,
because there is a
campaign of demonization
against these people
that is completely
the 180 degree opposite
of what the reality is.
The reality is they're
fleeing from terror,
and the tragedy is they're
being branded as terrorists.
And it's harder to get
to the US as a refugee
than through any other route.
It takes 18 to 24 months.
I don't know if in the '90s, but
now there's biometric testing.
Maybe even then there was.
AUDIENCE: At the time, all of
the process was done overseas.
So I had to go to an
interview with IRC.
DAVID MILIBAND: Interviews--
it's a really tight system.
I wouldn't have said this if
we'd be meeting last week,
but I think the following
point is really shocking, which
is that last year,
95,000 refugees
were allowed into the US.
This year the president
determined that only 45,000
would be let in.
In fact, his administration
is making sure
that only 21,000
are being let in.
But those are just numbers.
I want to say this to you.
And I apologize for
saying it, but I
think it brings it
into stark perspective.
More Syrians were
killed on Saturday night
in a chemical weapons attack
than had been let into the US
in the whole of
this fiscal year.
44 Syrians have been
allowed into the US
since October the 1st, 2017.
11 have been allowed
into California
compared to 680 that were let
in in the whole of last year
to California--
I think 1,800 across
the US for Syrians.
So there's a real
moment of crisis
where your voice is going
to decide whether or not
this bipartisan US
program-- remember,
it was Ronald Reagan who let in
more refugees than any other US
president-- whether this
bipartisan program goes away,
is slowly and silent strangled
or whether it has the chance
to carry on making a
difference to the country.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: I
think part of the solution
is making sure that people
understand how important
the contribution of refugees.
And sir, your story of how
you came, and now you're
a prominent integrated
member of society giving
back, great community member--
I know our team went
to volunteer actually
at the IRC center in Oakland.
And something I
learned personally
from that experience--
we were doing
a little bit of going
over resumes and practice
interviews.
And one of the things I
learned is how cultural it is.
In America, you know that
you brag in a job interview,
and you put your best
foot forward and what not.
But in some cultures,
that's offense.
And you want to be very humble
and underplay your skill
set as you go into an interview.
So it was interesting
just as someone
who has been around the
issue for a long time,
but getting
personally involved, I
think, helps me get
more passionate about it
but also understand some things.
So for our Googlers-- for
our employees-- anyone who
is interested in
volunteering with IRC,
make sure you go to
go volunteer profile.
Let us know about your skills,
your passions, your interests,
and that way we can connect you
with IRC and our other partners
who are working on these kinds
of issues like the Jordan
Project or even in
Oakland or other places.
So we're going to open it up to
questions in just a little bit.
So if folks want to jump on the
Dory, it's go IRC dash Dory.
We'll get updated
questions from there.
But is there anything that
we-- so as the Bay Area,
you're at Google,
a tech company.
Some of our other friends are
also stepping up from tech.
Are there things
that we in particular
can do as you think about
all of the products that
are created here in the Bay
Area, in Silicon Valley--
the services that
we're creating.
If you could wave a magic
wand and say, hey, Google
and other companies and other
folks with these skill sets,
this is what we need you
to do, what would that be?
DAVID MILIBAND:
So I think that's
the revolution that was
conceived in this community
and that has changed the world
in the last 10, 15, 20 years.
That revolution hasn't really
hit the humanitarian sector
yet.
And I think we've got to be
honest and say and warn you not
to try and bring a technological
solution to every problem.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
As we're wont to do.
DAVID MILIBAND: Well,
I didn't say that.
You might say that.
I couldn't possibly comment.
But there is a danger
that we try and find
hard technology
solutions to things
that aren't amenable to that.
But with that
provisor and warning,
there are things that
we really struggle
with because the revolution
hasn't yet hit our sector.
One obvious point-- we
work in places where
connectivity isn't very good.
And we are now in
a situation where
thanks to [INAUDIBLE]
leadership we've
got all of our
196 field sites up
to the standard of
connectivity of Nairobi,
which is approximately 70
kilobytes for a download,
25 for an upload
whatever that means.
But it's expensive for us.
It's really expensive.
So this business
of connectivity--
it's cost, how it can
be extended, how we can
help our teams work offline.
That whole agenda is really
important to our financing
and our sustainability.
Second thing is that data
inputting and ensuring
that our record keeping about
individuals, about products
is really top notch
would help us a lot.
One of the first
things I was impressed
with about IRC when I joined--
we developed our own
QR reading system
for making sure that
when we were shipping
medical supplies into
Syria we were able to track
where they went to.
Because obviously, the
business of ensuring
that aid is not diverted
into the wrong hands
is important to us.
So the record keeping
thing isn't just--
the data storage thing,
the data management
isn't just about our personnel,
although that matters.
if someone's sacked for sexual
harassment in one office,
we don't want to rehire
them in another office.
So there's a personnel
aspect to it.
But there's also
nutritional information
on some of our patients.
We help 360,000 patients
in the southwest of Syria
at the moment.
We want to make sure that
we're able to do that
in an effective way, so
there's a whole data management
aspect to it.
The third thing that I think
we're not very good at yet
and where you might
be able to help us
is on knowledge management.
We run a really fantastic-- one
of the things I'm most proud of
is our outcomes and
evidence framework.
We're very hard headed.
We say every program has to fit
into our outcomes framework.
All our programs should become
evidence-based or evidence
generating.
If you type in IRC outcomes and
evidence framework to Google--
I'm not just saying
that because I'm here--
but if you type it
in, you'll be guided
through what our
field managers can see
and how they should be
addressing the problem.
But how we manage the
knowledge behind that,
how we manage the
experience behind that
we don't do well
enough at the moment.
And so those are
the kind of things
where I think you
could be helping us
with the distinctive
technological skills
you've got.
One other thing which came
up when I went to the Oakland
office yesterday--
we haven't done a good
job on our alumni.
I'd love to do an
alumni project with you.
We resettled last
year 15,000 people.
We've been resettling
refugees in America
for the last 40 or 50 years.
Andy Grove was a
resettled refugee
by the IRC, which is
pretty extraordinary.
His name was András Gróf.
He was a Hungarian refugee.
We got him into the City
College of New York in 1957.
We bought him his
first hearing aid,
because he'd had
rheumatic fever as a child
and had never been diagnosed.
And the rest is history.
But we've not got a good
alumni records, even locally.
So there's all sorts
of ways I would
guess in which the
combination of your interest
and your skills might
be able to help us.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Super.
OK.
Well, why don't we open up
to the room for questions?
And we can also take some from
the Dory for our live stream
folks.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Thanks very much.
Excellent talk.
My name's Scott Campbell.
I work with the UN
Human Rights Office,
usually based in central
Africa or in Geneva
at our headquarters.
And first of all, thank
you for the comments
on immigrants' rights
and how they're
being demonized these days.
It's something our
commissioner for human rights
feels very strongly about
and is very outspoken about.
It's super important that IRC
also is taking that stand.
My question-- I'm just visiting.
I'm fascinated by the way that
IRC has captured technology
for promoting humanitarian work.
The question I'm
looking at while I'm
visiting San Francisco is
how technology can be used
to promote human rights work--
how we can use it as
the Human Rights Office
in the United Nations to
better protect and promote
human rights.
And I think your point,
David, [INAUDIBLE]..
There's not a
technology solution
for every problem is one we've
learned early on in the game.
But that said, I think IRC
is far ahead of the UN Human
Rights Office in how
you have carefully
developed with Google some
tools that have worked well.
Do you have any lessons
learned or thoughts
on how technology could be
used in a human rights context
rather than a humanitarian one?
Thank you.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: I would
say number one very humbly,
I think one of the biggest
mistakes we in the tech
industry tend to do
is develop solutions
in our nice little
conference room
here with catered food and
whatnot that don't actually
work on the front line-- so I
think starting with partners
like yourself, like IRC who are
on the front lines who really
understand the needs.
And then I think the other
thing that the teams did well
is we actually sent folks to the
crisis areas, especially UX--
user interface-- experts
to understand the needs
and to understand even if
technology is a solution.
So if we're talking
about direct service,
I think having folks who
specialize in human-computer
interaction and understanding
what the actual real felt needs
are and whether or not
technology can be a solution--
so I would say that particularly
for the front lines work.
I think as far as advocacy
though and other ways
to help those who are
leading on human rights--
Alphabet, our company, has
several different groups.
Jigsaw, for example,
has been working, for,
example, with DDoS attack
protection for those
who are on the front lines of
journalism and human rights.
So there are ways that we
can think as a tech community
about how we can ensure that
people's lifelines remain
intact when they do
their heroic work
as well on the advocacy front.
DAVID MILIBAND: The UN
Commission of Human Rights,
by the way, Zeid al-Hussein,
has done an outstanding job
in the last four or
five years to speak up
against human rights abuse.
I would say that this is
an additional challenge
for this community.
I think Jackie is
absolutely right.
You've got to have
the principles
of human-centered
design if you're
going to make a difference.
You've got to put yourself in
the position of that client.
Now, here's something
where I think
is the biggest challenge
in respect of human rights
abuse, which is that
it's not safe for those
who are abused to report it.
This is spoken as someone
who's obviously not
from a tech state.
If there's a way for the girl
in Northeast Nigeria who's
being threatened by Boko
Haram, the woman in Congo who's
having domestic or
sexual violence,
the people in Douma
who are getting
attacked by chemical weapons--
if there's some way
of allowing them
to anonymously but credibly
post in a way that can't then
be tracked back either
by their government
or by their husband
et cetera, I think
that could be a
really important--
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Witness
is doing something on that.
DAVID MILIBAND: Because that is
where the impunity comes from.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: You have
to be very smart, obviously,
about the reporting.
I think some of us
when we just use
our cameras or whatnot
don't understand that there
could be watermarks or whatnot.
So I think Witness is someone
who's doing good work.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask you
a question about the design
challenge of resettlement.
I read an article recently which
really troubled me suggesting
that the UK was doing a
much worse job than Germany,
for instance, in this
regard, because we give
a fixed budget per refugee.
And therefore, many refugees
that settled in [INAUDIBLE]..
It seems like a fundamental
design challenge in an area
where maybe data
analytics and insights
could be brought to
bear to do a better job.
What are your best practices?
DAVID MILIBAND: Great question.
Perfect, lovely question.
The US also gives a
fixed amount-- $3,375
to get resettled.
And it's the same if
you're in Boise, Idaho
as if you're in Oakland.
And in Oakland, the security
deposit on a apartment--
I probably don't need to tell
you-- cost $2,250 apparently.
In Boise, it's $750.
And surprise,
surprise, the issues
of debt for refugees
arriving in the Bay Area
are much greater than the
issues of debt arising in Boise.
So one, standard
cookie cutter services
don't work well in any context.
You've got to personalize them.
Some people have got
mental health issues.
English language issues.
You've got to try and
personalize the service.
And one of our big
drivers that we
have around outcomes
and evidence
apply in our US programs as
well as in our global programs.
If you click on--
well, actually, you
can't click on the
[INAUDIBLE] at the moment,
but we can find a
way of getting you
the evidence of what we know.
So the first thing is
you're right you've
got to personalize it.
Secondly, there's a
really important question.
Which people should get
sent to the Bay Area,
and which people should
get sent to Boise, Idaho?
And at the moment, it's done
in a relatively rough and ready
way.
But we're doing a project
with Stanford University
that I think you would be
interested in with Jeremy
Weinstein and his team there.
If you actually
developed an algorithm
for where you deploy people,
you can get 20%, 30%,
or even 40% improvements in
their chances of success.
And I think they've published
an article in a journal
somewhere about it.
But the second thing
is, let's figure out
where to send people.
Even before you start
spending the money, where
you send people can
make a big difference.
What kind of skills
have they got?
What kind of skills are needed?
What kind of community is
there is really important.
The third and most
important point
is that while the money may
run out after three months,
the problems don't run
out after three months.
And so you got to see
people through for longer.
And often, the
biggest challenges--
they only emerge in
a post-trauma phase
not in the immediate
trauma of arrival.
So there's a lot we've
got still to learn,
but I'm confident that
we're taking seriously
the really tough things.
So I was in Dallas visiting
our US office there,
and a guy came up to me.
He's a local psychiatrist.
He's volunteering with us.
It shows you that the
kind of personalisation
of services that you need
is really wide ranging.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Let me
take a question from the Dory.
So this is from Joseph.
So how does the ROI--
Return On Investment--
for tech aid
compare with that
of traditional aid
of basic needs such as medicine,
food, shelter, et cetera.
And what framework,
if any, do you
use to assess when to
deploy which type of aid?
DAVID MILIBAND: Well
thank you, Joseph.
It's a good question.
I think the way to answer
it is to think as follows.
First of all, your
category of non-tech aid
needs to be broken down a bit.
So for example, you mentioned,
I think, food and tents.
The best thing to give
to people is cash.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Agree.
DAVID MILIBAND: Which
immediately takes you back
into tech questions, but
cash is an empowering,
choice-based mechanism.
It also has an advantage way
beyond even the most efficient
food system or tent giving
or fleece giving system.
Do you know what it is?
No, you were saying
yeah as if I was--
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
No, I'm agreeing
that unconditional
cash transfers
through mobile technology
are great innovation.
DAVID MILIBAND: Well, the
unique advantage it has
is that it brings money back
into the local community
for the benefit of
the host community.
The tents and the food is
usually sourced a long way out.
We did a study in
Lebanon to show
that for $100 of cash
that is given to refugee,
$214 circulates in
the local economy.
So don't just think about
as tech versus survival,
I think he said.
Secondly, we are running
value for money studies
across different products.
How much does it cost to
set up latrines in Jordan?
set up latrines in Iraq
even within Iraq?
What's the cost of
a survivor's program
for gender-based violence
versus a vaccination program?
Those can raise
difficult questions,
but they're worth asking.
They don't fit into an easy
teach versus non-tech--
I think just to give you
a really profound example,
we found that
diagnosis of pneumonia
was really low in the areas
that we worked among kids--
20% more or less.
And the way we got from a
20% diagnosis of pneumonia
by parents and carers
to a 65% diagnosis--
they'd been issued with
stopwatches by the World Health
Organization, I think.
But the carers and
the parents weren't
able to count up to
the 40 or 50 or 60
breaths that were meant to
be counted within the minute.
So we issued a
necklace of beads,
and it requires the carer
or the parent simply
to flick a beat down
for every breath.
And when the child's number--
and it's different necklace
for different aged kids.
But when the number of breaths
reaches a dangerous level,
the color of the beads changes.
And when the color
of the beads changes,
that then tells you
what medicine to apply,
and we got our detection
rate up to 65%.
Now, it's not a
high-tech solution,
but it's a very high
value for money solution.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: OK.
I think we have
another question.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your time.
[INAUDIBLE]
I'm not a Googler.
I'm actually from TIAA-CREF,
which is a teacher's pension
fund here in the United States.
I work very closely with
Karen in various fund raising
activities.
I noticed that the IRC has
done some pilot microlending
programs in California.
I'm very excited
about this program.
My question to you is, how
important is microlending
in your view as a CEO of IRC?
Within your
organization, how much
would you support
and promote that?
DAVID MILIBAND: Well, three
of our offices around the US
have got what we call centers
for economic opportunity, which
are doing business loans.
I tell you the inspiring thing.
We do car loans in
many of our offices--
I think 13 or 17 of our offices.
The repayment for car loans
among refugees is 98%.
In case you didn't know--
you can Google this--
but the repayment rate
amongst the rest of
the population is 88%.
So it's quite a good push
back against the idea
that refugees are feckless
and irresponsible people.
They pay back their car loans
with extraordinary commitment.
But we're excited about this
economic opportunity model.
We want to spread it.
We're trying to tap in some of
the financial institutions who
work on the community
reinvestment trust areas.
It's not quite the
right wording of it.
So I think it's a good model.
We have quite a lot of
experience of small business
loans for women entrepreneurs
around the world
which are also very, very
successful and really quite
positive.
There's a big debate,
it's worth saying, about
whether microlending
is the world's
on the sorts of the
problems of poverty,
because there's
quite a lot of data
now to show that it's not
as simple as it sounds.
And there's now quite
a lot of dispute
about the long-term
income effects,
but that's for another day.
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Unconditional cash transfers
are showing very
strong results--
and then on top of that,
probably specific loans
for specific purposes.
Great.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Rachel Taber.
I work with 1959 Coffee Company.
We help refugees find jobs
in the coffee industry,
and I'm former IRC Oakland.
DAVID MILIBAND: Fantastic.
How have you got all these
amazing people into this?
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Yeah, you're the draw.
AUDIENCE: But I was
curious about a comment
you had made originally about
how three offices had to close
and that you would
touch upon that later.
And I think for those of
us in the service sector,
we're so distanced
from what is going on
in DC and with the
current administration.
And I just didn't know
if you had any light
to shine on that info,
how you see it going now,
how you see it
going in the future.
You say a 45,000 person
ceiling and 21,000 coming in,
and we're all like--
you know.
So just anything you
can share on that--
DAVID MILIBAND: Thanks
for giving me the chance.
The numbers are
as I've described.
There have been no congressional
hearings about this.
It's the Department of Homeland
Security who run the interviews
around the world.
Obviously, DHS didn't
exist in your time,
but the predecessor did.
And we've got to
generate some pressure.
So it doesn't matter
if you're in a--
some people say, well, I've
got a Democratic congressman,
so it doesn't matter.
No.
Your congressman
could make a fuss
about this issue to try and
get some congressional pressure
on it.
I'm going to see the governor
of Washington state tomorrow up
in Washington state,
surprisingly enough,
from Seattle.
Although is it Olympia?
Is that the capitol
of Washington state?
So we've got to
try and generate--
my way into this is to
say, this program is
going to be killed
unless people wake up,
because that's the
clear trajectory.
And it's bureaucratic
strangulation
that's going on at the moment.
The facts are plain.
The numbers are actually
published by the State
Department-- the PRM.
The Population, Refugees
and Migration part
of the State
Department publishes
the number of refugees coming
in, so it's not a secret.
But there's so much
else going on--
I don't need to say-- that
it's quite hard to get
some hearing on this issue.
But I do think this
point that the cry
about the fate of the people
in Syria is absolutely right.
But there are small
things that can
be done for equal
numbers of people
who managed to escape from
Syria that aren't yet being done
whether they're needing
employment support in Jordan
or whether they're
needing resettlement here.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: We have kind
of a follow on from the Dory
on that from [INAUDIBLE]
who asks, so how
does the IRC approach refugee
resettlement in today's
environment where an increasing
number of politicians
and Western democracies
are adopting
anti-immigrant rhetoric
and policy stance?
You've kind of touched
on this, but we're
seeing this across a number
of different countries
all at the same time
sort of surprisingly.
So what's been most
effective that you've
seen that you can do and
then general public can do?
DAVID MILIBAND: Well, the
only thing that is effective
is not me talking.
It's refugees talking.
What people will remember
from the hour we've had
together is you
speaking, because it's
the real human story.
And I think that
we have got to do--
we spend very little
on communications
and advocacy, because
we want to say, look.
90% of our money goes into
the field into our programs.
But actually, storytelling
of the refugee,
the staff, the emergency--
that's really important.
We were talking beforehand
about trying to do a better job
for Googlers so that if
you're one of the 5,000--
hopefully it will
become 10,000--
Googlers who are
supporting IRC, you'll
get to see more of the
difference that you're making.
But I think generally we've got
an amazing social media team,
but they're doing
it on a shoestring.
The most powerful
thing is to get
people talking in
their own voices
with their own stories
and their own credibility,
because it's so much
harder to point the finger
and say, no, that's spin.
It can't be spin if you
are the person who's
actually been through it.
Who's next?
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for being here today,
for the work that you do,
and for sharing it with us.
How do you change somebody's
mind or heart in one minute?
You mentioned that
whether it's a politician
or whether it's a
member of our family
or a coworker that thinks
that a refugee might
be a terrorist or
a danger to them--
if all we have is one minute,
with anybody else in the world,
you might be able to provide
one minute of how you change
somebody's heart or mind.
DAVID MILIBAND: Well, we have
this business radio show.
I don't know how many of you
know this radio show in the UK
called "Just a
Minute" where you have
to speak without
hesitation, repetition,
or deviation for one
minute on any subject,
and then people press a
buzzer if you hesitate,
repeat, or deviate.
So it's a brilliant program.
I'm not going to get into that.
I tell you what.
There's two approaches
to your minute.
There are people like
me who are probably
a minority of the population who
like as many facts as possible.
So I'm like Mr. Facts.
That would be the
way to persuade me.
And so one in 3.64
billion chance
of being killed by a
refugee in America.
88% of the world's refugees
are in poor countries,
not in rich countries.
America's only taking 90,000
in a population of 25 million
refugees, et cetera, et cetera.
So there's a fact-based
approach, which probably is not
the majority taste.
Or there's is a
story-based approach,
which is essentially to take
the individual story-- to take
the story of a young man
born in Budapest in 1936.
He has rheumatic fever.
He escapes when the Soviet
Union crushes Hungary in 1956.
He's helped to escape.
He goes to a city
college in New York.
He gets his PhD at Berkeley.
He's "Time" man of
the year in 1997.
And he's Andy Grover, and
he's the founder of Intel.
The trouble with the
statistics approach--
JACQUELLINE FULLER:
And, by the way,
we could as Google
tell those stories
with some of our founders
and CEOs and leaders.
Google would not be who we
are without folks who have
been given the opportunity.
DAVID MILIBAND:
Sergei did a big thing
when he turned up
at the airport.
He was there at San
Francisco airport.
That was a big statement.
But the problem
with the statistics
is that people don't
like statistics.
The problem with
the individual story
is that the people
can, say, oh, yeah.
But that's one story.
That's not the typical.
So the best form of elevator
pitch is to combine the two.
But really, I think all
you can do in a minute
is get people to think.
You can't persuade
them in a minute.
You can get them
to think, and you
go from thinking to
rethinking to persuading.
And one of the big challenges--
sorry, this doesn't
sound pretentious
or finger pointing--
but one of the dangers
of what you've all
managed to do over
the last 20 years
is that the space for thinking,
rethinking, and persuading
is being squeezed
rather than expanded.
And that's being
debated in Washington
with Mark Zuckerberg's
performance today.
But it's an irony that the
world has become quantumly more
connected over
the last 20 years,
but the space for people
to persuade each other
has become quantumly
shrunk over the last 20
years in my perspective.
People are talking to
people who agree with them.
They're being targeted by
Politics has become
about mobilization
of people who are
already on your side,
not persuasion of people
who are not on your side.
That's not only because of tech.
I mean, in this country it's
because of campaign finances.
It's because of redistricting.
It's because of a range of
undemocratic dysfunctions.
I don't want to sound
pompous about it,
but creating democratic space
for thinking, rethinking--
for hearing, thinking,
rethinking, persuading--
hearing, listening,
thinking, rethinking,
persuading is one of the
great challenges of the age.
Because if we're
not able to exhibit
those virtues of hearing
and listening and thinking
and rethinking, then the central
promise of a free society
is lost.
And it is a extraordinary
state of affairs
that 25 years after the
fall of the Berlin Wall,
the countries of autocracy
and of dictatorship
think that they
are the future not
the countries of liberal
democracy and free thought.
And the most
extraordinary thing is
that many of the people who
live in liberal democracies
think it's the dictatorships
that are the future.
I'm going to get this
wrong, but something
like 60% of under 25's
in democratic societies
think China does a better job
of thinking through its policies
than the West.
I haven't got the
statistic quite right,
but there's a book
by a man called
called Yascha Mounk which
is really interesting
book about the
fate of democracy.
And the point is
that in some ways,
the Chinese are
doing a brilliant job
of being strategic.
They're doing a
brilliant job at thinking
over a 10, 15, 20-year
span, and they're
doing a brilliant job of joining
up their different policies.
Without wishing
to get political,
there are plenty of
Western democracies
that don't exhibit that
kind of strategic clarity
over two days, never
mind two or 20 years.
And so your question,
I think, leads
into a really important debate--
which is obviously something
for a different
occasion-- but does
speak to something
that Jackie said
that I think is really important
which is that the stand off
in respect of refugees
is a symptom of a deeper
set of a deeper malaise.
And the argument in my book
is that after the Second World
War, the better
treatment of refugees
was a harbinger of the
peace and prosperity that
would come from a different
international order
after the Second World War.
The danger now is that the
mistreatment of refugees
is a harbinger of a
worse international order
over the next generation, and
that's what together we've
got to sort out.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Wow.
Well, join me in thanking
David for his talk today.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
DAVID MILIBAND:
Thank you very much.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Again,
if you haven't read it yet,
we have some copies here
today-- but excellent book.
And thanks to the team
at IRC to the work
that you do day in and day
out, and thank you so much
for your partnership.
DAVID MILIBAND: Thank
you very much, Jackie.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Thank
you all for joining.
[APPLAUSE]